[Music]
the information opinions data and
statements contained in this podcast are
not necessarily those of the us
government or the national institutes of
health and should not be interpreted
acted on or represented as such
welcome to the first episode of the
national institutes of health office of
equity diversity and inclusion women's
engagement committee podcast
i'm joy postel the women's employment
portfolio strategist and chair of the
women's engagement committee the
national institutes of health is part of
the u.s department of health and human
services the nation's leading medical
research agency making important
discoveries that improve health and save
lives
thank you for joining us for today's
podcast
over the next several months the nih
women's engagement committee will be
hosting insightful discussions
born out of the qualitative and
quantitative data around women
today's discussion on women in i.t will
be broken up into multiple parts to
focus in depth on specific issues of
interest
for this podcast we are honored to be in
conversation with the director of the
national library of medicine dr patricia
brennan and the director of
communications for the center of
information technology ms sarah moffitt
before i get into their distinguished
bios i want to share some eye-opening
information about women in technological
fields
we have seen some great women in tech
history over the years dr grace hopper
hedy lamarr
mary wilkes catherine johnson just to
name a few
they've certainly loved their marks on
society but according to built in
in 2021 only about 25 percent of the
jobs and technology are held by women
leaving women grossly underrepresented
in the field
moreover
moreover women only hold about 14
of software
software engineering and 25
of computer science related jobs in the
us and 37
at the nih
recent women in stem statistics show
that women hold about 18
of undergraduate computer science
degrees
because computer science research jobs
are expected to grow by 19
by 2026
it's time to talk about this but before
we do
allow me to introduce my guests dr
patricia brennan
dr brennan is the director of the
national library of medicine and lm at
the national institutes of health where
she oversees the world's largest
biomedical library
welcome and thank you dr brennan
thank you very much
my next guest is ms sarah moffitt
sarah is an i.t communications and
change management expert currently
serving as director for communications
and digital experience in nih's center
for information technology
welcome and thank you sarah moffatt
thank you so much for inviting me i'm
really happy to be here thank you for
for being here
my first question i like to direct
toward dr brennan
when some of us think of information
technology we may not readily see the
connection between i.t
and health research
how does the mission of nih intersect
with information technology
thank you very much for letting me start
with this question as you may know nih
is embarking on its very first
i.t strategic plan
information technology is core to the
operations of the nih and to the science
we produce
it's essential to be able to recognize
that as research grows what grows what
helps it to grow is the information
infrastructure that supports not only
communication but data capture data
analysis and data presentation
we recognize for example that team
science is a critical part of the
biomedical research enterprise and
linkages through
information technology networks internet
2 and virtual engagement has enabled us
to cut to partner with investigators
around the world
in the clinical care arena including in
our own clinical center
here at the nih the care of patients is
often monitored through electronic
devices and the integration of that care
with the care across the rest of their
everyday living is managed through
electronic health records systems so i
would say health and biomedical sciences
has become an intense information
technology enterprise no longer
sufficient to be the creative response
and activities of a biological scientist
or a good clinician but supported
enabled and extended by information
technologies everything from
telemedicine to the cryo-em the major
electron microscope that we have now on
the campus that's allowing us to peer
into single cells we could not do
science without information technology
wow
thank you for that that explains a lot
i think i have a much better picture of
what it is that you do
and what your office is about
uh sarah can you tell us a little bit
about why you chose this career path
what intrigued you about it
yeah thanks so much and dr brennan i'm
just so impressed and so happy to be
sitting here virtually next to you
this is quite this is quite a thrill for
me
um
so
i i sort of fell into this field
stumbled into it like i think a lot of
people do
my father was a senior level programmer
and developer at the united states
secret service so i grew up around techy
stuff
i grew up listening to tech speak and
just sort of figuring out technology on
my own
and i had an opportunity to work as a
technical trainer at a help desk at the
faa and that was my first it job almost
20 years ago
i had zero idea what i was doing and so
i just started
looking through the help desk tickets
and noticing where the patterns were and
so if like 15 or 20 people said they
were having problems with a certain
program i would go and learn how to use
the program and then
write training for regular people on how
to use it
um and i birthed faa's technology on the
fly training program
uh i'm a big fan of puns
so from their different roles i had
different goals i was in iso i've been a
dba
um and through those different roles it
helped me evolve my interest and skills
and realized that my skills and
communication
and talent development and helping
organizations get through big technology
changes
um
that's where i really love to be and
that's where my talent skills developed
and i have been incredibly fortunate
to meet wonderful people along the way
who have encouraged me in this field
despite the fact that i still cannot
properly code a single thing
well
sarah i can barely turn my computer on
so
my head goes off to you
very interesting thank you for sharing
that
dr brennan why did you choose this
career path
in
1975 as a student graduating from a
program in nursing i read an article
about computers and what they were doing
for nurses and although i had planned to
follow into a career in psychiatric
nursing i became increasingly
curious about how we could harness this
power for nurses the most complicated
thing a nurse face is
how to make a decision now not knowing
what the future will bring in response
to that decision whether it's medicaid a
patient comfort a family member or call
a
colleague so i was interested in
decision support and the only way to
study decision support in the late 1970s
was to look into computer science and
engineering but what was lucky very
fortunate in my career is that i managed
to connect with an engineering team that
helped me to understand the systems
around work and how to integrate
technology as a part of those systems
over time i realized that if we were
going to make advances in health in our
society we had to get these powerful
tools into the hands of patients having
them in clinics and doctors offices and
research labs was not going to be enough
so most of my career has been spent
building testing and evaluating
technologies to support people living at
home alone
very interesting
you know i'm even thinking about the
days when
you would go to the doctor and they
would have to write everything down on a
piece of paper
and you know before there was the system
you know and i'm like are you going to
really collect all of this information
but
wow that seems incredible but i
it is life-changing it really is it's
it's fantastic
i'm going to switch gears just a little
bit and ask
either of you
can you tell me well
we know that the data suggests that
organizations fare far better with a
diverse workforce we know that about nih
for sure
what do you make of the gender gap
between men and women in information
technology careers
is there a gap
or
what do you think what is
what's going on there
sarah do you want to give it a step
first or you want me to try
yeah and you know
i've been um when i came into this field
uh there was 12
12 of women in the it field
and now that number is roughly
not nih but i would say you know in the
united states and globally it's around
25
interestingly
there are actually now if you look at ic
squared's um
2019 cyber
paper on women in cyber there are more
women in i.t and cyber leadership roles
than there are men
which is
very interesting and something i think
we can have a big conversation about but
um
you know
i think that
i i t and site i call it cyber right
that's what the cyber workforce kind of
encompasses all things
i t cyber security intel
all of that the field is so big and we
tend to think of it
in a very small way i think a lot of
people think of it as like computers
they're not thinking about the
groundbreaking research that's being
done
at nih using information technology
they're not thinking about like how dr
brennan got into technology they're not
thinking about
um
cyber forensics or
uh different kind of coding or strategic
planning or governance or risk like the
field is so big and we just don't do a
very good job of kind of sharing
all of the different ways that you could
get into the field and i feel like that
because we don't share that because we
don't give
that breadth and depth of what i t or
cyber really is people have a very
myopic view of what it is and they and
they just sort of they just sort of see
it one way
and i
the the
kind of sad part right now that we're
seeing is we're seeing a high level of
women leaving the field
and
that's very concerning um in fact we're
seeing that in in many different careers
we're seeing a high level of women
leaving the workforce
and that is due to covet and because
women for better for worse still carry
the lion's share of responsibility for
taking care of their family so if you've
got
you know
uh compromise folks at home you need to
take care of if your children can't go
to school
it's a lot of the women who are leaving
the workforce so there's
there's a there's kind of a dual
challenge i see right now in recruitment
and in retention of of women in
technology
so i want to pick up on something that
sarah indicated which i think explains
the difference and the disparities of
participation and what we think is psyt
and what actually is it so it's been
much bemoaned that the percentage of
young women graduating with p with
bachelors and phds in computer science
has dropped precipitously since the
1980s so women were looking maybe 30 35
40 of the classes in the 1980s and now
they're down to about
15 to 20 percent
but the opportunities to understand to
learn and to make use of information
technologies have broadened so the
traditional training places are not the
only training places where you can learn
about technology and how it serves in my
home institution where i was before i
came to nih the university of
wisconsin-madison the most innovative
course in virtual reality is being
taught in the school that we once would
have called homec it's now taught in the
department of design studies in the
school of human ecology but it's because
the designers
needed the computer science knowledge to
be able to accomplish their designs and
the ability to have the right
environment to train people
at that intersection of design
visualization and computation existed
only there now computer science is
catching up i would say there's a new
school of information science and data
science at
the wisconsin and so they'll catch on
but what i think we need to look at is
the broadening ways where information
technology is shaping knowledge work and
lives and how we're engaging people in
those so the fact that we're losing
women from traditional training programs
shouldn't be looked at alone we should
look at what is society developing now i
will still say we lag there is a lag in
in both social recognition and social
compensation for positions so a
professor of computer science makes five
times what a professor of design studies
in the school of a human ecology makes
and so needing to look at the parity of
value as opposed to the parity of degree
is where i see an opportunity coming for
us in the future the federal government
is actually in the best place to do this
because of our competency competencies
and the way we advertise for jobs and
our jas jq's i forget what that that
operation is called when i'm looking for
a computer scientist in my lab in the
ninr i'm able to explain the the role
that that person is going to have
independent of the degree that that
person has so we are as we look for
computer science as we look for computer
science support in the computer science
job category i must admit
we were able to
work with hr to appropriately label that
computer science education may have come
from design studies
media arts industrial engineering
computer engineering not only computer
science and we work to look at the
competencies and the content that built
the skill not the degree
wow
so with that being said what do you
suppose
increasing the number of women
in computer science would mean to the
nih what could it mean globally
well i believe women bring lateral
thinking into conversations and lateral
thinking and information technology are
not well aligned all the time our comp
our computational tools are catching up
though with lateral thinking with the
idea that you can have multiple pathways
to a desirable solution as opposed to a
single pathway to the best solution
so i believe that by stimulating by
challenging by pushing the boundaries of
coding of systems design of
architectures of our data repositories
we will be seeing an enrichment of
technology where the technology will
catch up with our scientific thinking
and i believe that will happen because
of the conceptual framing that women
bring to the conversation the value of
precision single factor solution and and
um
and a a precise expression of language
in coding has been supplanted with
scripting languages with multiple
pathways to visualization with with
using technology to complement human
imagination as opposed to supplant human
judgment so i i have great uh great hope
for a future that will only continue to
be better
wonderful i totally agree and that's the
good news right yeah it really is and
you and
there are more women coming into the
field i will say we've got some great
opportunities right
there are
minority women are still highly
underrepresented in the field of i.t
um i think the statistic i read was that
of the 25 of women in i.t less than
seven percent are african-american which
is
heartbreaking yeah in this day and age
it really is and so we have a lot of
work to do
but
and i hate i hate just to like kind of
stereotype what i think are
you know women's traits but i will say
when i think of it and cyber and those
kinds of fields i think
that this is uh i think of women as the
ogs the original geeks right and and i
think that you know we are so creative
and we are such um communicative you
know we're we we're problem sellers
solvers we're people leaders we're
outside the box thinkers
and so i think that growing the
workforce with women here at nih and
globally is a tremendous opportunity and
i also think it's a really great
opportunity for us to
hyper focus on recruiting
underrepresented folks just to bring in
the diversity of thought and thought
leadership in this field
one of the things that i believe
is a tremendous and and still not
completely tapped opportunity is the
pathway into health that information
technology offers young people
so
you we we have in our culture in the
western culture we have so tightly
aligned
healthcare and personal service personal
characteristics a compassionate
physician a kind nurse and we we have we
have sort of restricted health care to
be nice people doing complicated things
for sick people and and not everybody
wants that career but there are young
men and young women who could contribute
massively to health care if they saw it
as a high-tech operation if they saw by
coding in high school you can change the
way we understand lung disease or we're
able to reach families in rural areas so
i believe that we have when you speak of
untapped opportunities sarah i think
that we have the chance that nih has the
opportunity to do this just bring these
young data fellows and our coding
fellows and our code-a-thons bring these
young people in to see that they can use
their tech skills in very creative ways
in healthcare and that this is a way to
improve the health of our society to
live out a social commitment through a
technological
skill
we just
i'm telling you like my heart's beating
that was
so powerful and so i mean
what a call to action
absolutely i believe here
so sarah um do you have any advice that
you would give to women and girls
considering a career in this field
yeah um
and i want to say
you brought some of this up earlier and
uh some of these ladies but i would say
advice for women and girls considering a
career in technology i would say
look at catherine johnson the
mathematician who helped put a man on
the middle look at grace hopper who
helped develop cobalt which is one of
the first high-level programming
languages and invented the first
compiler
which is a program that translates
programming code to machine language i
would tell them to look at the women in
world war ii who are behind the scenes
decoding enemy messages i would tell
them to recall that it was women who
wrote the code that makes missiles
undetectable and i would say this field
is made for you
do not be intimidated your mothers and
your grandmothers and your aunties and
your role models have shown you
that i.t and cyber fields are where
women have
and i believe where women will continue
to thrive and whatever your passion is i
believe that there is very likely a way
for you to express that in i.t
excellent that's inspiring i think
that's great i think the idea that you
tap into a passion of a person and you
guide them into how i.t allows them to
express that passion in the world is a
fabulous way to bring young people into
i.t
it is the
realization of one's own motive power in
a practical way and the mode of power
may be
not simply creative it may be financial
it may be the flexibility to run a
family it may be the opportunity to work
from hawaii the the i.t careers were the
first careers that became virtual became
distance became digital and so
i encourage the opportunities that young
women are looking for in terms of future
lives to see how i t can enable that
future life for them
beautiful
i have one last question
and if you can sum it up in just a
couple of words by finishing this
sentence the future of information
technology for women is
opportunity
go ahead dr brennan i just said well
thank you um i said i would just say
it's limitless we don't know the future
because they will create it
totally agree i you know limitless i'd
say full of opportunity and
and as we continue to up occupy more
real estate and leadership in it and
take the opportunities in front of us
we have this opportunity to kind of
bring in others um and and create this
kind of world of leading ladies i love
that uh in the field of i.t limitless
opportunity i love that
dr brennan miss moffett
i am inspired
thank you for your time for sharing your
stories and your thoughtful advice and
on behalf of the women's engagement
committee in the office of equity
diversity and inclusion edi at the
national institutes of health thank you
for joining us
and look for future episodes right here
and check out the edi webpage at
www.edi.nih.gov
i'm joy postel principal strategist for
the women's employment portfolio
until next time
[Music]